the eye of Hurricane Maria just came
ashore in Puerto Rico the storm weakly
weakened slightly overnight to a strong
Category 4 but officials there predict
entire towns will have to be rebuilt
Maria's top winds as you see are now 155
miles an hour
overnight it pounded st. Croix one of
the US Virgin Islands David Beck know is
in San Juan Puerto Rico which is
directly in Maria's path David good
morning the winds are ferocious right
now gusting above 120 miles per hour
severing the tops of the palm trees and
ripping off the boarding that's on
buildings there's a high-rise about a
hundred yards behind me and it's
continually tearing pieces of the
building away and they're flying through
the air like projectiles we are in front
of a hotel right now the safest place we
found and inside everyone's been
evacuated to the bottom floor but in the
lobby pieces of the ceiling started to
fall so they took them into an emergency
stairwell even the police are here with
us it's too dangerous for them to be out
right now this is the best safest spot
for them Hurricane Maria barreled
through st. Croix overnight before
roaring ashore in Puerto Rico this video
was taken just outside of our hotel room
showing the force of Maria's violent
winds it was enough for the hotel to
order guests down to the lobby level the
region was still rebounding from the
last storm
Irma with Maria rolled in we've never
had any back-to-back hurricanes before
Yolanda Maldonado has been without power
since Hurricane Emma
two weeks ago now she's in a shelter in
San Juan I passed through hurricane but
this one it's gonna be very high Eddy
Negron and his 11 year old daughter just
Co D for riding out the storm in a hotel
room we are trying to do the best we can
to survive you can see this one as well
it's said it's wood we were with Puerto
Rico's governor when he walked the
streets yesterday personally pleading
with people to evacuate to a shelter can
the island of Puerto Rico survive a
direct
it's from a category four or five we'll
take a big hit but our people are
resilient and they're strong we showed
it after Irma we were there to help
other US citizens in their time of need
now we're going to need a helping hand
here's an update to the situation going
on at the hotel where we are in San Juan
the managers have told our crew that
there's nowhere else to bring the guests
other than that emergency stairwell that
is the last resort for them the winds on
the streets of San Juan right now are
making it impossible to even see down
the street it's literally a wind tunnel
and we're told Charlie that this is
going to continue for probably the next
six hours David Beck now in Puerto Rico
thank you so much David